So here's a thought, right.
Communication is an
attempt at a transgression.
It's an attempt at
crossing over and entering
the mind of the other,
or rather bringing
the other into one's own mind.
Communication is an
attempt at a kind
of intersubjective
coherence, right.
It's a means to achieve
a shared mutuality,
to enter an intersubjective
space together.
And I think that language is
one way to tell each other what
we mean, so to speak.
But when language
becomes visual,
right, then we can
show you what we mean.
And one of the things
that Terence McKenna,
the psychedelic
philosopher, talks about
is that virtual
reality technologies
allow us to turn
our minds inside out
in the very same ways that cave
paintings, early art, pottery,
poetry allows us to turn our
interior world into something
that can be visibly beheld.
Language can be seen; I
can show you what I mean.
In new technological
paint brushes,
magic mirrors, electronic
devices, camera lenses,
like this, further
extend this capacity
to objectify our inner
world, to take the inside
and make it the outside.
To show you what I mean
I can record this video,
I can play it for you,
and I can be over here
with you, beside myself,
showing you what I mean.
And ultimately the desire
of the two of achieving this
is then to feel close to
the other person, to bond,
to be able to share that
hinting recognition,
to have that cosmic wink,
to know that we are both
experiencing the same
thing at the same time
and you feel less alone and
you feel recognition again,
to say that again, and
it's a powerful thing,
right, to show each
other what we mean.
And I think that's the future
of communication technology,
to further extend
this capacity, ,
this linguistic desire to
meld the minds together.